It's official: Marvel Phase Three is here.
So what the heck does that mean? Well, for
one, it means that many of your favorite characters
are about to take a dirt nap. Here's a look
at some of the huge characters that will probably
die in the Marvel Cinematic Universe Phase Three.
Number 1. CAPTAIN AMERICA
No spoilers, but in the comic Captain America:
Civil War is based on, Captain America gets
killed. Wait, did we say no spoilers? Sorry.
But that's not the only reason we don't expect
Cap to make it out of Phase Three alive; while
star Chris Evans has spoken publicly of his
desire to continue working with Marvel, he's
also been forthright about wanting to work
behind the camera instead of in front of it.
Evans might be around for Phase Four, all
right. He's just more likely to be directing
Stan Sebastian as the new Captain America.
RIP, Steve Rogers.
Number 2. THOR
If there's one thing we learned from studying
Norse mythology, it's that Ragnarok is very,
very bad. After all, it involves the destruction
and death of all the gods. So expecting Thor
to survive the events of Thor: Ragnarok is
beyond optimistic. There is some hope, though;
in the comics, Ragnarok is an endlessly repeating
cycle of death and rebirth, so it's possible
Thor could be reborn. But he'll have to die
first for that to happen, so don't be surprised
when ol' goldilocks takes a permanent arrow
to the knee. Or gets reincarnated as a woman, which I would totally be cool with.
Number 3. THANOS
At this point, big cosmic baddie Thanos has
almost had more cameos than Stan Lee. But
in the two-part Avengers: Infinity War, Thanos
is finally going to get the spotlight—and
it's going to be a bloody one. Thanos, after
all, worships Death. So even when he inevitably
loses, he still gets what he really wants
most in the end. The question isn't whether
Thanos will die, it's how many heroes he'll
take down with him. Speaking of which…
Number 4. IRON MAN
Of all the stars powering the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, none is as important as Robert Downey
Jr.—and none have been quite so up front
as Downey about being tired of putting on
his costume again. So it shouldn't come as
a surprise to anyone if Iron Man makes the
ultimate sacrifice in Avengers: Infinity War,
especially given the clear foreshadowing of
exactly that in Tony Stark's dream sequence
from Avengers: Age of Ultron. At least it's
probably going to be epic.
Number 5. THE VISION
Tony Stark is just one of many heroes we're
expecting to meet their end in Avengers: Infinity
War. Chances are that The Vision is going
to join him in perpetual rest. Why? Well,
the synthetic man who stole every scene in
Avengers: Age of Ultron was given life by
the Infinity Stone he wears on his brow—and
Thanos is going to need that stone in order
to complete the Infinity Gauntlet. Hopefully
someone will be able to rebuild Vision after
Thanos dismantles him.
Number 6. DRAX THE DESTROYER
Drax the Destroyer's entire reason for living
is to exact vengeance on the villains who
killed his family. And that means Thanos.
It's inevitable that Drax is going to get
a showdown with Thanos at some point, but
given their relative power levels, it's also
inevitable that Drax is going to come out
on the losing end. Don't be sad, though. When
you think about it, is there really any other
way the single-minded Drax could go out?
Number 7. GAMORA
Drax isn't the only member of the Guardians
of the Galaxy who has a grudge to settle with
Thanos. His adopted daughter Gamora is also
one of many looking to permanently wipe that
giant grin off of Thanos' ugly mug. Given
that he trained her to be the universe's deadliest
assassin, she has a better chance than most.
But, like Drax, Gamora has one big thing going
against her odds for survival: in the comics,
they both were killed by Thanos. Hey, it ain't
easy being green.
And at number 8 - EVERYONE
If it sounds like pretty much everyone you
care about is going to die, that's because
they are. In the comic book Infinity Gauntlet,
which all of the cosmic stuff in the Marvel
movies is based on, Thanos actually wins and
kills everyone. Don't be surprised if that's
the cliffhanger ending to Avengers: Infinity
War Part One. Of course, eventually Thanos
is defeated anyway and most of the heroes
are resurrected, so don't worry, the Marvel
Cinematic Universe will survive. Whether you'll
survive the stress of the viewing experience,
though, is another question entirely.
Thanks for watching. Don't forget to like and subscribe if you want more.